au lieu de pratiquer le rafting dans les
montagnes rocheuses passé donc vos
vacances en tipi au coeur de la meuse
des tipis d'indiens aménagé pour assurer
quand même un minimum de confort
deux associations depuis sept étés lance
cette grande première en lorraine
catherine bommel est parti sur le
sentier de la reconnaissance
un petit vent sioux entre les côtes de
meuse plus fort que le gîte rural plus
corsé que le camping à la ferme voici le
tipi l'habitat traditionnel des indiens
d'amérique qu'à trouver au départ j'ai
une double vocation touristique et
culturel parmi les promoteurs du projet
un agriculteur passionné par l'élevage
des chevaux mais qui consacre la moitié
de ses activités aux animations
touristiques par goût mais aussi par
nécessité vont bien trouver des
activités nouvelles sachant que bon les
mes surfaces agricoles sont augmentés on
a du mal à trouver du terrain encore
pour l'instant ça va peut-être changer
et il faut trouver des activités qui
nécessitent peu de terrain et qui qui
permet d'utiliser le flot touristique
est-ce que c'est facile d'être un
agriculteur touristique
il y a beaucoup de compromis enfin il
faut accepter le chahut le soir il faut
il faut il faut s'ouvrir il faut il faut
bien sûr être l'accueillant il faut
penser un petit peu aux besoins et les
réaliser notamment dont les points d'eau
etc
il faut il faut réagir un petit peu en
en hôteliers c'est pas toujours facile
face à l'agriculteur touristique qu'un
indianiste convaincu ancien animateur du
joug des passionnés l'écologie c'est lui
qui dispensent le b à ba de la vie sous
tipi c'est vrai que vivre dans un tipi
traditionnel un tipi indien nist sa
demande déjà à quelques compétences
qu'on ne peut pas acquérir en cinq
minutes et tout l'objectif du travail
que j'ai réalisé avec mes copains ans
rené suite et d'avoir rendu d'essayer
d'avoir d'andré dreux tipi accessibles à
des personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
les compétences nécessaires faire du feu
savard vivre occuper l'espace tipi
traditionnelle alors le plancher sur
tous les outils à feu y compris la
grille par est un sel sont destinées à
sécuriser les gens et à leur donner la
possibilité de vivre confortablement
soutif i quel que soit l'âge même si on
a des enfants et même si on veut vivre
une expérience qu'ont portal et non pas
une expérience de survie ou christie
comme ça la flamme il vient leçon numéro
un le feu une étape essentielle qui fait
tout le charme du tipi
puisqu'il est possible et même
recommandé de cuisiner ou de s'échauffer
au feu de bois montre en forêt et après
les choses deviennent un peu différente
avec un tipi bateau-feu confort et qui
peuvent être très grands d'un type et il
faut toujours faire des tifs c'est mieux
pour la sécurité et pour économiser
louadj rage aussi je suis plus doucement
oui il n'y a pas besoin et violent avec
le feu habiter dans un tipi permet un
rapprochement indéniable avec dame
nature c'est un véritable art de vivre
qui rompt avec le camping de masse
l'expérience qui vient d'être lancée ici
correspond à une véritable étude de
marché si le tipi réussi à convaincre il
pourrait devenir un maillot du
dispositif touristique d'un des
départements les plus verts de lorraine
pour nous le tipi c'est un nouvel
habitat des côtes de meuse qui apparaît
aujourd'hui et qui semble bien l'adapter
à ce qu'on veut lui demander mais le
tipi n'appartient pas l'histoire locale
non c'est pas lié à l'histoire locale
mais l'histoire elle se fait tous les
jours
alors voilà maintenant les tipis font
partie ni stars le club le far west à
deux pas de chez vous qui sait peut-être
que les slogans touristique meusien
auront bientôt un petit quelque chose
dessus